systems work the Dana toradora more on
the nature of the Gods is a very
interesting work from a number of
different perspectives and if you're
interested in stoic philosophy
particularly in their understanding of
the cosmos how human beings been into it
and what we call their religious
conceptions this is a really important
work to peruse and so I strongly suggest
that you do get it and read it's
available online I'm also going to see
to that the video for this day is not
going to be quite so long and involved
as the videos for the previous cicerone
Ian worse in part because I already have
a three part video series in my intro
philosophy class videos specifically on
this dialogue so if you want to see more
about this you can just go to those now
back to this this dialogue so it is a
set of dialogues in three bucks three
chapters through long chapters again
it's between representatives of the not
necessarily the most they were there
actually you could say five major
schools of antiquity but three of the
biggest heavy hitters on the scene in
Cicero's time and that is the epicurean
school the stoic school and the academic
skeptic school there are also the
Platonic Academy that it revived itself
from from skepticism eventually and then
there were the resilience but they don't
enter into this dialogue so each one of
the books is devoted to one of the
philosophical perspectives and bow too
we get this very lengthy presentation by
a stoic proponent let's call them not
necessarily a philosopher Quintus Lucas
Balbus but someone who really does know
his
well he understands the doctrines he's
able to argue with the other
interlocutors quite a bit since Rome
himself appears to be holding out for
the skeptic view more than the stoic
view he's rather dismissive in the way
that he sets it up with the epicurean
you that's done with it book one but the
stomach view is a bit more for it the
question is can it actually be proven
through through argument now one of the
reasons why this work is is very
interesting from the perspective of the
history of ideas is that many of the
themes in in philosophy particularly
were philosophy and religion intersec
then we would otherwise be tempted to
attribute to the coming of Christianity
or of Judaism and Christianity into the
philosophical field Lee of the breed and
Roman cultural sphere you know for
example arguments for the existence of
God that's something that if you take a
philosophy of religion class you'll
probably not begin with reading ancient
philosophy you'll begin with reading
medieval philosophy probably beginning
with you know people fairly late on in
like an some and Aquinas now the stoics
themselves were quite interested and so
were the Epicureans by the way even
whether you could argue for the
existence of gods and the skeptics were
interested or if there we go the
skeptics were interested in whether
these arguments really had any weight or
whether you can produce counter
arguments to them I will see another
thing to from the advantage point of the
history of ideas when you look ahead to
the modern period there is a philosopher
who is a big fan of Cicero who is going
to take this dialogue and arguably use
it as a model for his own dialogue
about religion and about whether you can
argue you know successfully about the
nature of God or the divine somebody who
is going to have a dialogue concerning
the actual religion again in with three
interlocutors each of whom represents a
particular school you know I leave it to
you to figure out who that that is
that's sort of nice it's very easy
puzzle to figure out so it's you've got
google at your disposal but it is
interesting to think about there are
some strong structural parallels between
this word and that later philosophers
work who was a big admirer of cicero all
you need to do is read his works and
you're going to see the pepper with
quotations from cicero so what I'm going
to do if you not here are just three
main points I'm actually only going to
talk at length about two of them because
I got I'd like you to read the work and
I want to keep this a little bit shorter
on arguments for the existence of God
the Stoics had some arguments some of
which strike is today is being pretty
bad arguments as manufactured skeptics
of the time of like well that's a
terrible argument and some of them have
a little quite a bit going for them the
distinction between religion and
superstition the stoics did believe in
say Zeus and Apollo and in Minerva and
in other gods as well but what do they
think about them do they think that they
were like the gods as they're depicted
by Homer engaging in all sorts of
shenanigans with each other did they
think that the the worship of the god
should be the way that the the ordinary
peasant the the country bumpkin the
pagano's in Latin did it or they have a
more refined conception of days so we'll
talk a little bit about that and then
I'm not going to actually go into any
any review of this because you can read
this work there are some very lengthy
discussions in this word
about the that are aimed at making a
case for Providence and they tend to be
also making a case for a design or a
teleological argument for the existence
of God so you know that's a significant
portion of the work you can read that on
your own where you can go to the other
videos and see me teaching a class about
that but let's talk about these two the
arguments for the existence of god and
the distinction between religion and
superstition
so in the on the main truth of God's in
book 2 where the stoic doctrine is being
presented still arguments are being put
forward about the nature of the Gods
which includes whether the gods exist or
not baldness will actually reference
what can be picked out as five distinct
ways of arguing for the existence of god
or gods or the divine and I want to hit
on some of these and say a little bit
about them in part because I want you to
get interested in taking a look at this
word and thinking about the fact that
arguments from God's the arguments about
God's existence did not just come on the
scene in the so-called age of faith but
they were part of Greek philosophy
really on as a matter of fact Cicero is
not the first person to be talking about
this Aristotle talks about it at one
point in various works but it's not
diminish the matter this year it's being
done very thematically so if you want to
argue for the existence of God is really
two signs of it right if there's some
way of demonstrating that there is an
existence there that that this is not
just a figment of our imagination but
you also give an exception of God this
is where the Stoics are particularly
different in an interesting way from
later well actually in some certain
respects you know at least researcher in
the religions contemporary religious
viewpoints right the the god of Judaism
and Christianity and Islam is a
transcendent cats not part of the
universe the universe is created and
God's it is whatever God is is somehow
not just sort of outside the universe
video and bomber pervading universe for
the Stoics the universe itself it is
divine so this is a very different
conception not only is there this divine
all you know a kind of pantheism but
there are also gods
who tend to be for the Stoics understood
as things like stars and we'll get to
that in a moment when we talk about the
religion and superstition issue so
here's the five arguments that he has
the argument from common consent or you
might say common ideas the argument for
miracles the argument from design or
order of the things that we can we can
observe an argument from intelligence
which is a different kind of argument
and then an argument from degrees of
being an these are not you know
rigorously distinguished from each other
in this flowing discourse of all those
who by the way is also citing
cruciferous with an earlier stoic
philosopher as having provided some of
these so if we only had Christmases
works which unfortunately we've lost we
might be able to read greater length
some of these things so the argument
from common consent is it runs basically
like this look everybody's got some
conception of the divine they may not
agree about you know precisely what it
looks like but there's at least some
general conception that everybody has
about a dating right so he says here we
go if a person doubts that there is such
an idea then we just have to look around
nothing but the presence in our minds of
a firmly grasped concept of the deity
could account for the stability and
permanence of our belief in him a belief
which is only strengthened by the
passage of the ages and grows more
deeply rooted with each successive
generation of mankind this is an
interesting idea isn't it I mean
especially for us in a very secular age
or you say oh well people used to
believe it should be a common thing and
now there's more and more people who are
just purely secular or even militantly
secularizing they don't believe Cicero
is actually having ballaz
you know at that time you know more and
more people are actually believing we
would come across all of these different
groups he says in our own nation and
among all others reverence for the gods
and respect for religion grow
continually stronger and more profound
nor is this unaccountable accidental it
is the result of some other things and
then we get into some other interesting
arguments but the the argument is we all
have the same general idea we're
actually getting clearer about it in the
process now is this a particularly good
argument I leave that to you to think
about I don't consider it a particularly
good one but I've got my own reasons for
that let's talk about the argument for
miracles another one that's not
particularly a good argument but which
does get made grab it and this one goes
more or less like this i'm not going to
read the texts the gods exist because
they manifest themselves to us they do
so by actually showing up you know we
know this from the poets and from
certain historians that the gods show up
and and do things for example on the
battlefield and then of course for those
who don't experience that well we also
have divination and you know how can the
gods tell us about what's what's going
to be happening how could there be
prophecy if there weren't any gods to do
it now I think you can see some problems
with with that argument you know why
does it have to be the guys why can't it
just be you know people seeing things
that aren't there how do we know that
divination really works there's a lot of
issues with this so it's not a very
strong philosophical argument the
argument from design I'm not going to
read at length because much of this
chapter is concerned with that and that
tends to be the way that design
arguments work you know a lot of people
will read for example in modern
philosophy William Haley's famous
watchmaker or
event and they don't realize that it
comes from a book of natural theology
that is thick and which the entire
purpose and piling up all these
different ways in which things are set
up the right way is to say there must be
some sort of cosmic designer who
actually makes things come out like that
well the Stoics did believe that God in
fact exercises a providential care all
the way down to the least details for
the entire universe so things are set up
the way that they are are you know for
example he's got the talk about the
human hands so they're so apt to do all
these other things or so fit for the
purpose that they are designed for
there's an order to them an order ring
and orientation as we might say so
designer arguments often work by you
know in the abstract or say look there's
design we observe it there must be a
grand designer otherwise you know we
would have had to come up with this we
didn't come up with it nobody else did
that grand designer is indeed God again
I leave it up to you to decide whether
you think that's a good argument or not
I'm particularly fascinated by these
last two arguments much more than these
other three so the argument from
intelligence sis or by the way is not
the only person to make this argument if
you look throughout the history of ideas
you will find other people making this
argument as well he says where did our
intelligence actually come from did it
just come as the epicureans thing out of
random interactions by the way the old
struggle between a conception of the
universe as having some sort of design
behind it and being random chance you
know just working out in certain ways
that was already there in the battles
between the Stoics and the epicureans
and the skeptics by the way on the
sidelines sort of cheering both of the
bottom and jeering at both of them he
says here we go we're do now here it is
intelligence must lead us to infer the
existence of a mind in the universe they
have a mind of surpassing ability and in
fact of I'm otherwise where did man pick
up as Socrates says and Xenophon the
intelligence that he possesses if anyone
asks a question when's do we get the
moisture of the heat diffuser the body
of the actual earth earthy substance of
the flash and lastly the breath of life
of this that's fine manifestly derive
one from the earth the other water the
other from the air but where did we find
once did we abstract that other part of
us which surpasses all of these I mean
our reason or if you like to employ
several terms to denote it our
intelligence deliberation thought wisdom
is the world so remember the stoics
consider the world as listen totality to
be God it is the world to contain all
the other elements but not this one the
most precious of them all yet beyond
question nothing exists among all things
that superior to the world nothing that
is more excellent or more beautiful and
not merely does nothing superior to it
exists but nothing superior can even be
conceived and if there'd be nothing
superior to reason and wisdom these
faculties must necessarily be possessed
by that being which we admit to be
superior to all others so what does that
actually say there is a God because by
God part of what we mean is a being who
actually is you know transcendent while
these [ __ ] transcendent toss you know
the whole world in is rational and wise
why is beyond our own comprehend
our if we want to get all tonic about it
which probably should do is stokes we
could say our own intelligence is just a
dim reflection or participation in the
reflection rather the intelligence of
the divine hole so this argument from
intelligence is saying that God exists
because there is indeed some source for
our intelligence some hyper intelligence
interesting idea again I leave it to you
to ponder over finally there's an
argument from degrees of being that's
kind of mixed in with some of these
other arguments now the arguments from
degrees of being tends to work along
these lines we observe that there are
degrees of being so the stoics accepted
this the plainest accepted this the
Epicureans didn't really accept it and
some modern philosophies are not going
to be very receptive to this notion of
degrees of being but the Stoics you know
certainly it did did buy into this and
the idea is well look you've got bigger
being by itself and then you have living
the plants for example right but plants
are not as high as you can go because
above that again sentient living being
notice how you're you're adding
attributes in there but these attributes
are not just qualities that are being
added their greater amounts of being
their greater ways of existing so
sentient being is greater being that has
merely living being and living being is
greater being that is mere being is
there anything about sentient being well
there there is rational being the kind
of beings that we are we are at a higher
level right and then is there anything
higher than us or are we the highest
thing there is in the universe in terms
of being well that's where you get this
interesting discussion here we go
says the fourth and highest grade is
that it beings born by nature good and
wise and endowed from the outset with
the innate attributes of right reason
and consistency this must be helped to
be above the level of man sorry there is
a degree of being above us we are
rational rational some of the time not
all the time it's a fairly weak
instrument that we possess they're right
this fourth grade the highest grade you
know mere being doesn't count as a great
living sentient rational kinda rational
capital are being he says this must be
held above the level of man it is the
attribute of God that is of the world
which must needs possess that perfect
and absolute reason of which I spoke
says again it's undeniable every organic
whole must have an ultimate ideal of
perfection a highest degree of being as
it binds our cattle we see that I'm less
obstructed by some force nature
progresses at a certain path of her own
char goldful development and is in
painting architecture the other arts
there's an ideal of perfect workmanship
even so and farm and word of the world
of nature as a hold there must be a
process towards completeness and
perfection the various limited modes of
being may encounter many external
obstacles but there could be nothing
that can frustrate nature or God he has
a whole since she embraces iment
Ainsworth herself all modes of being so
it follows there must exist this fourth
and highest grade unassailable by any
external force so he goes on now this is
the great on which universal nature
stands since she is of such a characters
to be superior to all things than am
capable of frustration it follows by
necessity that the world is an
intelligent being and indeed also a wise
being and that is you know two pair
phrase Thomas Aquinas in the case of
stoics that is indeed what we call God
so the Stoics are producing this
argument from degrees of being which
will by the way you get taken up by
other non stoic philosophers later on
have used similarly to argue now for the
existence of the world as this Divine
Being before the existence of some sort
of transcendent be so a lot of
interesting discussions going on here if
you want to see the attacks on those
arguments you need to go to book 3 where
the skeptic is going to criticize those
and then you know give a little other
material of his own towards the end
about you know the fact that he's a
priest at hospice skeptic at the same
time
another aspect of this text that I think
people may find quite interesting
particularly if they're you know view of
the history of ideas is that first
there's you know the Greek and woman pig
and age and then there's you know
monotheistic religions coming on the
scene is the fact that the stoics
themselves they actually made a very
strong distinction between true religion
and superstition superstition here we go
that's superstition and Cicero provides
a kind of lexical discussion of that
here he said that puts us in all this is
mouthy says religion has been
established from superstition not only
by philosophers but by our ancestors
Roman ancestors people who spent whole
days in prayer and sacrifice to ensure
their children should outlive them
returned superstitious from super stays
a survivor and the word later acquired a
wider application those are the other
hand who carefully reviewed and so to
speak retraced all allure ritual we're
called religious from Renee going to
retrace or reread like elegant from any
good I think if something's other
examples for all these words contain the
same sense of picking out laga me that's
present in religious has superstitious
and religious come to be terms of
censure and approval respectively now
you know is this lexical derivation
really genuine well we don't really know
and cicero himself doesn't really know
it's kind of an interesting idea but
what's really important here is the fact
that they are distinguishing very
strongly between religion and
superstition and we'll read some of the
other parts of this text to you as well
we're talking about that there's a
theory that the Stoics can and it's not
just you know the stoics themselves are
in many ancient philosophers we have a
similar theory about the origin on
recognised conception of the gaps how do
you recognize something he has
how do you start calling say the thing
that suits the Thunderbolts Zeus right
or how do you assume that Apollo is
somehow connected with music but is also
responsible for plagues and for the
healing of plays well there's a couple
different ways in which this happens
when there's some specific benefit to
human beings then that that you know the
word of that benefit or the thing itself
like in the form of canneries you know
what we get cereal from ordinator in
greek which which Cicero says is from
gaming chair mother earth you know
there's some sort of specific benefit it
gets dignified right it gets turned into
a divine force some other potent force
becomes a god so for example Venus or
Aphrodite the goddess of desire you know
the designer that overcomes a sexual
desire not just desire to go ahead stick
gum or watch some TV but a real hardcore
desire which Cicero says that's more of
a voice than anything else you know then
that's recognized as a divine force
distinguished people and like Hercules
end up getting day ified as well now
this is an interesting theory that the
stomach's have how do these guys connect
up with their real conception of the
gods which is that you know these are
sort of cosmic forces almost sort of
like the way some people think of angels
not that acute see [ __ ] angels that
that people put up greeting cards or
stuff like that but those that are sort
of responsible for the governing of the
universe there are quite a few religious
conceptions out there if you do your
homework oil Footwear you'll find there
is a God of the capital cheat and then
you might say a whole bunch of other
divine beings God let's let's call them
who would do a lot of the day-to-day
management of the universe um that's one
interesting point another really
important point is that the Stoics in
gage and allegorical reading of the
poets and religious texts and rituals so
let me give you an example of this here
an ancient belief prevailed throughout
Greece that Kyla's heaven right or
arrows and greed was mutilated by us on
Saturn and Saturn himself thrown into
bondage by us on Joe now though these
immoral immoral fables enshrined a
decidedly clever theory the meaning was
that the highest element of celestial
ether or fire which by myself generates
all things is devoid of that bodily part
which requires union with another for
the work of procreation so you know
they're saying Rudra knows never have
any parts to cut off because it doesn't
procreate in that way by a Saturn again
they denoted that being which maintains
the course and revolution of seasons and
periods of time the deity Ashley so
designated in Greek for Saturday's Greek
name is Chronos which is the same as
Kronos a space of time the Latin
designation Saturday on the other hand
is due to the faculty is saturated or
satiated with the years the fables that
he was in the habit of devouring his
sons meaning here's where the allegory
comes in meaning that time devours the
ages and gorges himself and say shibly
with the years that are past Saturn
going on further with the allegory was
bound by Jove in order that times
courses might not be unlimited and that
Joe might fetter him by the bounds of
bonds of the stars but Jupiter himself
the name means the helping father the
poet's calling the father of God's men
and our ancestors entitled in the best
and the greatest putting the title past
that is most magnificent before that'
greatest again the allegory because
universal beneficence is greater or at
least more lovable than the possession
of great wealth so you see how they were
they are reinterpreting these great
ideas let's let's you know compare this
to the the other conceptions that we see
he says later on do you see how from a
true and valuable philosophy of nature
has evolved this imaginary and fanciful
fanciful pantheon they have a Greek
mythology that a superstition right not
an alloy your eyes superstition so the
perversion has been by a fruitful source
of false beliefs crazy errors and
superstitions we know what the guys look
like how old they are other dress their
equipment and also their genealogies
marriages and relationships and all
about them is distorted into the
lightness of human frailty human
weakness they are actually represented
as liable to passions and emotions we
hear them being loved sorrowful and
angry according to the myths they even
engage in wars and battles and that not
only when as in Homer two armies are
contending on the gods take sides but
they actually fought wars of their owns
like with the titans and the Giants so
Cicero's auntie says these stories are
nonsense this is just garbage that
stupid people the superstitious believe
we stow X's ball is talking right we
stoics have a purified alaga rised truly
philosophical way of understanding what
these stories only dimly suggest so the
last point that I want to get to is what
it actually says about the gods the gods
themselves are not going to be like
human beings passionate you know jealous
of each other screwing around with human
beings just to do so you know making all
sorts of all sorts of little Gods by
having sex with people the way that Zeus
generates a hope anthea why because the
gods are totally virtuous the gods
possessed the highest degree of virtue
they're not encumbered by you know the
same things that the bottlers human
beings they're also super intelligent
they know better than to do all that
crazy stuff that homer or whoever else
attributes to the
the play you know the the playwright's
the comedians all those people and even
better they exist in a kind of
Commonwealth a society a well-ordered
state which we human beings can to some
degree participating this is the stoic
idea of cosmopolitanism taken to a kind
of divine love where the the Concord the
the Commonwealth of the Gods provides a
model for how things ought to be for us
human beings on earth but so rarely are
remember to sister what is writing this
at a time when the Roman Republic has
just been torn apart and put back
together all a bunch of times where he
has been forced out of politics himself
and seeing the Republic to generate in
his view into an empire Imperium led by
a dictator or a triumphant so you know
this stoic conception of a true religion
it is going to be something very
different than what we ordinarily
associate with Greek religion you know
pagan Greek religion